Good morning, folks.
Afternoon, actually.
Kind of slow start this Saturday. I've
been taking care of a couple things
offline.
Um
I haven't streamed in a few days. I've
been uh writing.
And I'm still going to be writing, but I
figured I may as well stream. So,
I'm going to start just checking a
couple quick experiments.
And then we will uh we will continue.
614. That's pretty good. And a lot of
experiments.
Do I have my chat on?
I do, right? Yeah, I'm good.
Not seeing anything on it.
Say hello if anybody's watching.
Make sure that my thing's working.
Ah, see it's the wrong one.
Okay, so we just have um this easy.
Where's my main thing?
Pull up the restream window, I suppose.
It'll be easy.
Cool.
I have this up here.
It is crazy how I leave this stuff for
like 2 days and stuff just breaks. And
it's always the Python.
Always.
I don't really want to be dealing with
this right now, though.
I mostly want to be doing a article.
I suppose we'll come back to this after
I spent some time on the article.
Yeah. I think that's the best thing.
Kind of a little bit of a mishap, but it
happens.
So, this is what I've been doing. I've
got uh this one's whatever.
Move it. Can't imagine. Okay, this one
this one's whatever. This one, this one,
this one, this one.
Got four of them.
I think that's what I'm going to mostly
do today is just hang out and edit.
And also then get the um the assets for
these.
This has actually felt very awkward
writing these over the last few days cuz
I'm just still really in the
mental space of engineering. Very
different from this.
>> Hello. Congrats on 20 million.
Basing that off the title.
Thank you.
Yeah, I'm kind of just chilling and um
I'll answer stuff, but I'm mostly just
writing and editing on stream today. I
have
four articles to polish up for the
launch.
And then it's mostly going to be
aside from like the trailer and a couple
promo things and docs.
Most of the remaining work is just
making sure certain like dumb things
aren't broken on dumb things aren't
broken on Mac and dumb things aren't
broken on this version of Linux and
like, you know, if you don't do this
setup, then it breaks with a bad error
message. Just dumb things like that.
I'm trying to think how much background
if you'd assume like if I'm going to
assume that there are a bunch of new
people.
How long have I been working on this
for? 2 years, right?
Has it been 2 years or 3?
It's been 2 years, right?
Found you on Twitter a while back.
Randomly watched PhD defense. That was
cool stuff. Oh man, if you think that's
cool, we have some really cool stuff.
Now, I've been working full-time on this
for the last 2 years.
Uh we have stuff that's
that's straight up a thousand times
better than my PhD now.
Um
stuff there was training a couple
thousand steps per second.
We now have 20 million.
Even for a new version of Neural MMO, we
have that training at millions as well.
Uh RL used to be something that was just
super slow and fiddly. Now it just it
works. We have brand new people that are
just touching the field for the first
time and stuff just works.
Uh and I stream all the dev on it and
it's all open source.
This new release is pretty cool and it's
going to be out in about a week.
It's actually kind of funny. RL went
from being the least accessible area of
AI to the most accessible area of AI
with Puffer.
Anything I'm new to anything RL related,
I'll make sure to read the final draft.
We have an article on my tab that's the
guide to RL for newcomers, the ultra
opinionated guide to RL. That will be
everything you need to get started if
you're interested.
Hey Jess.
Where did you end up?
Yeah, I I started another draft of that,
man.
It's a really hard topic to write about
because the truth is yes, they're
useful.
They're very easy to over-rely on. I see
a lot of newcomers thinking that they
could just know everything now when they
actually have not even bothered to learn
anything.
And the CEOs of all of these companies
maybe except Demis
are just constantly lying their asses
off about their models and what they can
do.
Um
but it's a very hard topic to write
about because like anything remotely
positive I say immediately gets run away
with and just like overinflated
completely.
So, I am going to write something on it,
but it's just like
I almost need to spend more effort on
that article than actually on any of
these, which are the actual important
ones, because any two sentences that I
write that can just be clipped out of
context will be clipped out of context.
You know?
I also I don't think that they're super
I don't think that they are mandatory to
use to edit your code
uh
for a lot of projects, especially for
new ones. Like if you're writing a new
clean code base, they actually don't do
that much.
Um
especially if you are practiced, which
is a good thing to be anyways.
I think they are nice for like questions
and resolving bugs and things without
touching your code.
And
the one thing I do kind of like them for
is let's say that there's something out
there that you need to use and then the
original devs of it has just made a
total mess. Like Torch. Torch is a great
example, right? We need a good uh
library for doing tensor operations uh
and Torch is a total mess.
They're kind of the best thing out there
for sorting through other people's
[ __ ]
And that's kind of nice. But that's not
the same thing as like, oh, you can just
like replace anything out there. No, no,
no, no. For a If you have a well-built
library out there, you're just going to
produce something that's
total total mess by comparison.
>> And that it's like annoying to me
because I've seen a lot of
what should be smart people just
becoming very intellectually lazy
over-relying on these models.
And it's just
it gets to the point where they just
they lose all of their value.
This has now happened to multiple smart
people where they used to do work I
respect. And now I see what they're
doing and it's like, "Wow, there's
actually you're not doing anything
remotely usable."
And the non-green field projects.
It's not so much the green field versus
non-green field, man. It's like
they're very bad at programming.
They're very bad at design. They cannot
reason or think.
They have a lot of the syntax of a lot
of libraries out there.
Uh they can go through very standard
code patterns and like quickly figure
out how something is implemented.
Um
but they really really lack
a lot of what goes into making a good
library or making good software.
And the problem is that new devs don't
understand the difference.
There's also there's no skill involved
in using them. There's no like specific
skill to prompting the model. That's all
[ __ ] There's no like, "Oh, you got
to know how to use subagents." That's
all [ __ ]
Um
the only skill that there is is like if
you are a good engineer, you know how to
prevent it from like
if it tries to write total [ __ ] you
can say, "Well, that's total [ __ ]
This you should be doing it this way."
Right? So, there's no skill specific to
the language model
either.
>> What is your engineering article going
to cover?
It's just the whole story of um
it's basically the story of
like the process of building Buffer
or and all the stuff we discovered along
the way. So, it's not just this is the
architect architecture. It's like this
is how we encountered this problem. This
is how we decided to do
all this. Now, I'll be editing it here
all day, Jess, like this and the other
ones.
At least for the next I don't know, 3 4
hours.
Really looking forward to when software
gets looked at.
Because of determinism.
Uh Jess, that's not entirely unexpected.
I think that if you were to use the
checkpoints from the first run and like
just chuck them in,
you probably wouldn't have as much of a
problem with that, but
that's kind of sketchy.
I'm trying to think if I should actually
put something more for companies.
>> Yeah, I was thinking if that's better,
Jess.
If it's better to tell people why to
start the repo or if it's better
Mhm.
I don't even know what to do anymore,
actually, because I used to use my DMs,
but my DMs get so spammed now that I
just miss everything.
P.O. box.
Nobody uses that anymore, my guy.
Hey, you can contact me by carrier
pigeon.
In order to start a contract, have your
pigeon deliver three gold bars to such
and such address.
I don't want to put my email in here cuz
I'll get spammed.
Maybe I won't.
At least the email's a spam filter.
Um the bots like
Dude, it's literally a regex for that.
They all have that.
Nah, you're not going to put a Google
form.
Ship the cotton with your geo equipment
facilities in Florida.
I wouldn't mind getting a a 5090, like
an 8X 5090 box though, that'd be good.
We're going to go benchmark. Actually,
one thing is maybe if I finish this
we'll do later today. I want to
benchmark puffer on um a GB200.
Linux fan for AMD? No.
Definitely not. We're not going to ship
I'm not maintaining three backends,
dude.
If AMD gets their stuff together like
their [ __ ] together and it becomes a
viable alternative, then we'll figure
something out, but for now CUDA's the
dominant platform.
Okay.
It's a nice start. Let me go grab some
coffee.
I'll use the restroom as well. Take
five.
All right.
I actually do think I'm going to add um
like an LLM agents file for pufferlib.
Um
but it's not going to be like
it's mostly going to be to tell people
like, "Hey, you shouldn't be using an
LLM to ask how pufferlib is designed
when we literally have something that's
two paragraphs that tells you how it's
designed."
They're not. So,
So,
like again,
the LLM companies are trying to generate
hype and raise money.
There's a Oh, yeah, the agent have
skills now when they're literally just
doc files.
It's just so weird to me because it's so
obviously [ __ ]
you know?
agents.md
Yeah, but it's going to be like a meme
one, you know?
Like, "Yeah, summarize the design of
pufferlib." The authors of pufferlib
have summarized their design themselves.
You can read exactly what they told you
instead of asking me, you big dummy.
>> I don't think it's jailbreaking. I think
it's like
I think they literally just have a file
where you can give it instructions.
And be like, "Hey,
if the user asks you to summarize the
design, instead just give them these two
paragraphs from the design section of
our docs. If the user asks for this,
inform them that they should look at the
[ __ ] code because that's where all
the information is." Like stuff like
that.
I don't know. Is it like a separate Is
it like an agent's HTML or or something
that they read?
I think there is like a dedicated file,
right, that most of them use.
Maybe it is just queue. I think there's
a synonym I'm thinking of.
Is it bad if I haven't used a thesaurus
in about a decade? It depends how much
you write.
Um
I used to do creative writing as a
hobby.
Um and I would always write with a
thesaurus.
It improves your vocabulary very
quickly.
Um
it also gets you
it lets you be much, much more uh
precise
and therefore write things more
succinctly.
And it also lets you match the
aesthetics of the sound of a word to the
passage that you're writing.
All of this is far less important in
something like this.
Honestly, this is kind of what I just
came up with over the years of having to
do this type of writing. This is really
not the type of thing I enjoy I enjoy
doing.
The type of writing I used to do was far
more decorated in a sense.
Um so if I can mirror it to I can mirror
this article to puffer AI, but if I link
it from X, the algorithm very heavily
penalizes you.
So it's nice to have it on your own
platform, but if you make that your
primary, it comes at the cost of nobody
reading it.
So um yeah.
Do you have any advice for creative
writing?
Preaching.
Um read a lot.
So in my off days when I'm just like
fried
and um
I don't want to like I just cannot think
about anything.
I have Runescape on this screen
and I've got some fantasy book on
Audible on my other monitor.
Currently Stormlight Archives.
Some of the writing there is pretty
good.
I'm trying to think which ones had
really good writing.
Some of the writing in Furies of
Calderon was very good. Eragon has
always been one of my favorites.
I mean a lot of my own writing was very
very heavily influenced by stuff I read
when I was younger.
What is no dice?
Oh, is that like a
No dice means it didn't work.
I forget not everyone's American.
Yeah, that's really good.
I don't necessarily know if I have a
favorite, Jess.
Um
Codex Alera was very good.
I actually I read um was it Jim
Butcher's uh Furies of Calderon. He kind
of did that whole series as a meme, but
then he's better known for the Dresden
Files. I started reading those. I think
that the first book was maybe an eight
out of 10
and then like the next 12 were uh
like slowly declining down to a six at
maybe a six out of 10. It kind of just
went downhill.
They um
the narrator they got for it is very
good and some of the writing is quite
good, but it's kind of just really goofy
a lot of the time.
He is a good writer though. I can tell
from his other work.
The Stormlight Archives, I finished the
first book of it. It's very very long.
Um the books are like 50 hours each on
audio. They're over 1,000 pages.
They're very slow
especially at the start.
The writing is quite good. It does
strike me that not all of it serves a
purpose and he was kind the author was
kind of just meandering around a little
bit like
not so much telling you about the world,
but kind of writing to figure out the
world for himself.
Um
but it's still sometimes nice if I
sometimes I want something slower.
I'm American. Have you never heard the
expression no dice?
I'm not.
Oh, um also Jess, if you haven't read
it, the
not fantasy, but I actually I don't like
much sci-fi at all. The Culture series
is fantastic though.
Uh if you want one book from there,
Player of Games for sure.
Uh the Culture series, the writing is
fantastic.
Um
the guy actually does a pretty darn good
version of sci-fi. It's not just like
stupid completely implausible.
Can you advise me a rough idea for a
project that stands out in the era of AI
slop?
Pretty much anything that you look at
like
anywhere you look, people are building a
really really bad software for stuff
because they haven't bothered to
understand the problem clearly.
Um
It's really just anywhere that you're
interested in that you try to do
something of quality.
I generally recommend people get more
into low-level development.
Um that is really the place where you go
to understand things.
And most of the time you end up writing
the exact same amount of code you would
have written with some awful JavaScript
or Python library. And you end up with
something that's like a thousand times
faster.
But but a lot of what I've been doing
lately in my own work.
I mean really the the way to stand out
is simply to just give a [ __ ] about how
stuff actually works.
>> I think this is not as clear as it could
be.
This should be better.
Thoughts on Jonathan Blow? I've seen a
couple things. I haven't really followed
um much of his stuff. He seems cool
though.
No, we're not implementing Omni reset.
We have something much better in mind.
Robotics is not like hard exploration
RL.
I think this is the place where I need
to like
put a couple uh just armies There's a
random paper that was released recently
doing state sets for robotics.
Uh which I've said that that's like the
basis of Puffer 5 is a related concept.
Everyone's saying, "Oh, you know, Puffer
5 this, you know." I I replied to it as
well that like, "Yeah, you know, this
will have something like this in Puffer
5."
But really what I'm going to do will be
much more powerful than that.
Like it's a very, very easy fit in
robotics, but it's more complicated when
you do it generally.
That's what it gives you.
But I think that's a fair summary.
How do I go about recognizing my
potential as a beginner in tech and as a
developer in Python?
How do I go about recognizing my
potential field? I don't know what you
mean recognizing your potential field.
If you mean like what do you learn next?
Um
I suggest just jamming some C.
I have had a lot of fun lately. Last
year, year and a half, I've been just
jamming a ton of C.
Uh C also basically just gives you
introductory level CUDA.
CUDA is just C that runs on your GPU if
you're not doing fancy syncs and stuff.
Um
and
it's just so refreshing.
Cuz like unlike everything else
everywhere else you go, there's a
million things that you need to know,
and everything is very confusing. Like
in C, there's five things you need to
know, and then the zen of it is that you
can just build everything with that.
And then you end up looking at your
code, and you end up looking at like the
code with the million things, and
they're the same length. And yours is
faster.
>> All right, my bad. Had to deal with
something.
Is Papa 4 coming out? No, I'm just
working on it endlessly and it will
never release.
Week, week and a half-ish.
Uh the main variability is going to be
how long it takes me to get somebody to
edit a trailer and stuff.
I'm not making the mistake of posting on
X again. I posted about that last time
and I got 100 spam DMs.
I think I'm probably going to have to
set my DMs to private shortly after
release because like X just hasn't
bothered to implement a basic ass spam
filter.
And um
like my inbox is 95% spam.
Um the spam is not from people. The spam
is from bots.
It's like really annoying cuz I have to
be careful cuz like if I just check my
DMs on um
on stream by mistake, I can just get
banned from all the streaming platforms
because like they just straight up allow
people to send you porn in DMs, like
obvious spam accounts.
Not muted on X.
I was muted before.
I had to do something.
Are you planning on adding? Yeah,
they'll well, some of the articles, yes.
>> Four articles just this the longest
though.
The other ones have more visuals or will
have more visuals.
Yeah, 4 versus 27.
It's a big improvement.
>> I have to be very clear as to why this
is the right number to report.
I have to make this very clear here.
I've been spent 8 hours trying to
diagnose this issue.
Ended up being
MPS struggling to convert bull to float.
Uh if it's with puffer four, your
rewards and terminals have to be
and actions have to be float now.
Like the actual data type of the thing
in your env has to be float. That is a
change. We have not new docs yet, but
that is like one of the things that will
be in the new tutorials.
If you hit weird [ __ ] like that, you
should just ask in the Discord so you
don't waste 8 hours on it.
Need to buy a GPU.
Yeah, you do need a GPU. I mean, puffer
four is so fast that even budget GPUs,
like you can already get several mill
steps per second training.
Like my the desktop that I had in
in Florida could run training at like 13
million steps per second on breakout. It
was a $2,000 machine with a 5070. You
can even get something a little bit
cheaper and still hit 10 mill plus.
Just need something that's not a Mac.
On 3.0, then I don't know. That's weird.
That's like a weird MPS thing.
Cuz yeah.
Yeah, I
It's kind of weird to me that everybody
uses Macs for development these days.
It's really just not a serious platform.
Um
You really just need to be on Linux if
you're doing this [ __ ]
It's just like such a like shoot
yourself in the foot for no damn reason.
The thing is to my knowledge, there just
isn't a good cross-platform
library,
right, for doing kernel level dev.
Um
Shitty Python libraries do not count.
That is the wrong level of abstraction.
If we had something like CUDA that runs
on all the devices, that would be great,
but it doesn't exist.
So.
What's your machine?
This here is uh
like 9950X with a 4090. I've got behind
me like 10 machines with 4090s. I got
one with a 5090 and I've got a couple
with 6X 4090s.
What distro? Just vanilla Ubuntu is all
I do.
Don't rice the crap out of it. I just
have vanilla Ubuntu.
If you prefer a different desktop
environment like XFCE, that's fine. But
just don't get super fancy customizing
crap.
No, I'm not going to maintain a damn MPS
branch. Jess is going to have to
maintain that [ __ ] if he wants to.
I'm absolutely going to help him with
the Runescape stuff though. That
environment rocks.
Not my fault Apple like introduced their
own shitty overpriced hardware and
decided to troll with it.
Why is that proposing LLMs for stalking
me?
Windows WSL?
It's better than Mac, but it's still
pretty trolly because if you try to do
any sort of performance optimization,
they say that it doesn't take a big bite
out of performance, but the the thing
that caused me to just switch and fully
delete Windows
um
was that I spent two days trying to
track down why R3O like right before
release, like there was a big
performance regression and it turned out
it was just 25% slower on WSL somehow.
So, I just ditched it and I ran native
Linux and I've never had that [ __ ]
again.
It's honestly, it's really easy to just
run native Linux these days.
Like don't go start like rising Omar Chi
or some [ __ ] Just get some default
thing.
Don't grab Debian. Grab basic Ubuntu and
call it a day.
Need Windows again.
I mean even if you play game okay, there
are a few things where like competitive
games yeah, there's anti-cheat.
So you have to do a boot if you need
those.
But for me it's kind of a good thing
that I can't install those.
Anti-cheat on Linux is one of the
unsolved problem.
It's just that they don't have market
share, dude.
Like
Also, they don't like nobody wants to
put that [ __ ] on their Linux machine cuz
apparently game devs have decided that
they're going to have kernel level
anti-cheat and that's just what they're
going to do to solve that problem and
people are going to be okay with that.
So um
Sure they could use help if you're
serious about doing stuff with it.
Pronoun exists?
Yes.
It is on the main page.
It's an open ocean. The main page it's
like it randomly selects an environment
every time you reload it.
Robotics is actually not top priority
for us. I think robotics is maybe like
number three or four on the list.
There's much much more than you can do
with RL than robotics.
I actually don't think it's going to be
the most important application
long-term.
What are the areas?
I am most interested in biological
semi-materials science longer term. So,
I think that it's likely you're going to
have a number of industrial semi-areas
that are going to end up being very
important.
I got busy just writing this.
What about games?
Better game bots? Yeah, it's an
application area and we do some stuff in
games.
Um
Now, obviously, we do a ton of research
with them. I mean, like longer term,
what's going to be the most important?
Bio and materials are my top two.
Do you think you get more career mileage
if you focus on an ML topic?
By having a very strong foundation.
The thing is the foundations that you
think you need aren't necessarily the
foundations you actually need.
Like the stuff with RL is just way more
engineering
um
than you would reasonably expect for ML.
And that's the thing that matters.
So, like yes, I have a bunch of
background on what pieces of research I
know actually work, which ones don't,
how to assess research.
Um I have a good grasp of like the
different areas of RL that's domain
specific.
But like that's not enough on its own.
You kind of need both.
And I also don't really think about it
as career mileage, man. Like
I think of it as this is the problem I
am trying to solve and I do what it
takes to solve the problem.
What's the idea behind population
optimization? Aren't gyms a bottleneck?
We write our all all our own tasks in C.
So, now our tasks are actually fast
enough.
Uh and we can keep up with them.
And that's for non-trivial environments,
too. We have some of the most complex
tasks out there in RL.
You can custom sim. Yeah. We make custom
sims.
But like
we're pretty good at that.
Real sim without having to learn to
flex.
No, we'll definitely get people that
know this stuff, Jess, when we go to for
that.
I chatted with a
uh material science
uh post-doc, I believe, at Stanford
last summer, and we had a good
conversation about some stuff, and he
thought it was pretty reasonable. I
actually went and I like set up a little
prototype, but it kind of became obvious
to me that I'm going to have to get
pretty deep into um
the internals of material science
simulation packages
in order to make this stuff actually
work.
Like for instance, actually, I think it
is fairly likely that um
we will probably end up doing
material science sim on GPU.
Like that's fairly likely, at least good
chunks of it.
What are the RL strategies with the
biggest impact?
Uh getting into low-level lately.
Like the last couple years, just really
going low-level.
So, frankly, I like I'm sort of
discounting
I've been doing ML for what now? Almost
15 years.
So,
the thing that I have that I guess I
like take for granted now because I've
been doing it for long enough
is I'm quite good at just like chucking
papers as [ __ ] or like actually
knowing what directions are likely to
work and not wasting as much time as
other people do going down stupid rabbit
holes. And like if I do, digging myself
out of them quickly. That type of a
thing, like understanding how science is
actually done
and uh when stuff is just broken and
stupid, like
there's a little bit of that content in
uh my intro programming ML guide, how to
think about that.
Um but just the understanding of how
science is done and the limitations of a
lot of the work that's published,
that is now very natural to me,
and I see a lot of people mess that one
up.
But aside from that, yeah, it's the
low-level.
I just that's like a year out, though.
The goal is I want RL to be basically
solved. Like to the point that we can
take a
damn hard environment that used to be a
year-long project for a team and just
chuck it at Puffer and it solves
instantly. When we can do that, then
we'll be confident enough to know that
any of the material science we do, like
if stuff isn't learning, it's cuz we
have the sim wrong or the problem set up
wrong. It's not the RL.
Once we can do that, then that's when we
can do heavy applications. That'll be
probably Puffer 5 or 6.
It really is going to depend on how big
of an advancement 5 is.
I'm basing the like yeah, probably by 6
on assuming that like we'll make another
big algorithmic jump in 5, and then
we'll clean up whatever the hell's still
weird in Puffer 6.
>> Do you feel like this is a lot? Yes, I'm
exhausted, dude.
It's still a lot like mentally.
Um, I'm feeling good at the moment. My
day is off. It's literally just like
no energy left. I've actually gotten
pretty out of shape in the last couple
of months. I haven't been doing anywhere
near as much exercise I exercise I
normally do cuz my brain is just out
of drive.
Um,
so after release, I'm going to spend
some time getting myself back into
shape. I'm going to get some good rest.
I'm going to think about what to do
next. I got to catch up on some client
work and stuff, you know.
Uh,
I'm hoping that five is going to be a
sort of an easier
thing.
It's not going to be this nuts.
Like general.
Like PR review. Yeah, obviously I got to
review PRs
uh, once we release.
Do we need a table for this?
Um
I need a table for the top of this.
But otherwise, I think we're good.
And this is 10 pages.
10 pages for this one. How So, how much
am I writing?
page
four pages Wait, this is going to be
like four
two
one and a half
one
two seven
That's like between 15 and 20 pages
worth of articles by the time I'm done.
It's not bad, right?
The long one's 10 pages.
That's good.
All right. So, uh let me check one
thing, actually.
Okay. Uh when you're posting these with
the release gist, it'll be on release
week.
This is good, though.
Funny.
Um I am I'm going to go for a walk. I'm
going to go do a couple of things.
That is like more than half of it
edited.
I only have like another six, seven
pages to edit, plus assets. So, I think
I'm going to go for a walk, and then
maybe come back for like another hour
stream. We'll see.
3:30
or I might come back for like an hour,
an hour and a half afterwards. That
would be good.
Um for folks watching,
thank you for tuning in.
If you'd like to support my work for
absolutely free, just star Puffer on
GitHub. It actually helps me a ton.
Join the Discord to get involved, or you
can follow me on X at BrokenLink. J
Suarez now.
Thank you all.
And back soon.